energy is all around us
a physical quantity that follows precise
natural laws our universe has a finite
amount of it it's neither created nor
destroyed but can take different forms
such as kinetic or potential energy with
different properties and formulas to
remember for instance an LED desk lamps
six watt bulb transfers six joules of
light energy per second but let's jump
back up into space to look at our planet
its systems and their energy flow
Earth's physical systems include the
atmosphere hydrosphere lithosphere and
biosphere energy moves in and out of
these systems and during any energy
transfer between them some is lost to
the surroundings as heat light sound
vibration or movement our planet's
energy comes from internal and external
sources geothermal energy from
radioactive isotopes and rotational
energy from the spinning of the earth
are internal sources of energy while the
Sun is the major external source driving
certain systems like our weather and
climate sunlight warms the surface and
atmosphere in varying amounts and this
causes convection producing winds and
influencing ocean currents infrared
radiation radiating out from the warmed
surface of the earth gets trapped by
greenhouse gases and further affects the
energy flow the Sun is also the major
source of energy for organisms plants
algae and cyanobacteria use sunlight to
produce organic matter from carbon
dioxide and water powering the biosphere
is food chains we release this food
energy using chemical reactions like
combustion and respiration at each level
in a food chain some energy is stored in
newly made chemical structures but most
is lost to the surroundings as heat like
your body heat released by your
digestion of food now as plants are
eaten by primary consumers only about
10% of their total energy is passed on
to the next level
since energy can only flow in one
direction in a food chain from producers
on to consumers and decomposers an
organism that eats lower on the food
chain is more efficient than one higher
up so eating producers is the most
efficient level at which an animal can
get its energy but without continual
input of energy to those producers
mostly from sunlight life on earth as we
know it would cease to exist
we humans of course spend our energy
doing a lot of things besides eating we
travel we build we power all sorts of
technology to do all this we use sources
like fossil fuels coal oil and natural
gas which contain energy that plants
captured from sunlight long ago and
stored in the form of carbon when we
burn fossil fuels in power plants we
release this stored energy to generate
electricity to generate electricity heat
from burning fossil fuels is used to
power turbines that rotate magnets which
in turn create magnetic field changes
relative to a coil of wire causing
electrons to be induced to flow in the
wire modern civilization depends on our
ability to keep powering that flow of
electrons
fortunately we aren't limited to burning
non-renewable fossil fuels to generate
electricity electrons can also be
induced to flow by direct interaction
with light particles which is how a
solar cell operates other renewable
energy sources such as wind water
geothermal and biofuels can also be used
to generate electricity global demand
for energy is increasing but the planet
has limited energy resources to access
through a complex energy infrastructure
as populations rise alongside rates of
industrialization and development our
energy decisions grow more and more
important access to energy impacts
health education political power and
socioeconomic status if we improve our
energy efficiency we can use our natural
resources more responsibly and improve
quality of life for everyone